he might not be the x-men's most famous
foe but the juggernaut has been around
for over 50 years with a complicated
history that ties him to everyone from
spider-man to Professor X to Doctor
Strange if you want to know his story
here's the truth behind Cain Marko the
unstoppable juggernaut the uncanny X
brothers before the juggernaut even
appears on panel in uncanny x-men number
12 Professor Xavier fills the x-men in
on his origin story as a youngster the
smart and sensitive Charles was bullied
by his older stepbrother Cain Marko they
were rivals their whole lives
although Xavier was able to get the
upper hand when his psychic powers
manifested when the pair happened to
cross the sacred lost temple of CID Iraq
however King grabbed a ruby from a
strange-looking statue and it
transformed him into the unstoppable
behemoth known as the juggernaut the
cave collapsed and buried Marko but it
turns out that unstoppable wasn't just a
catchphrase years later Marko returned
to hunt down his stepbrother with a
distinctive helmet which made him immune
to Professor X's psychic powers that
first battle with the x-men like many
that followed was all about getting that
helmet off enabling Xavier to lay down
the psychic whammy I'm trying to attack
his mind but I can't get through his
helmet protects his mind from probes the
power of Sidra it wasn't mentioned in
the early stories but in 1992's Doctor
Strange sorcerer supreme number 44 CID
Iraq was revealed to be a demon who had
been banished to another dimension
he's a being of destruction and chaos
which is why he chooses earthly avatars
like Cain Marko and grants them the
power to cause untold devastation in his
name in a 2015 storyline sitter axe
appearance was redefined mirroring the
juggernauts traditional red armor and
domed helmet by making him a big red
creature with a large domed head by
giving shape to the character and
motivations of cid iraq and showing the
juggernaut as his earthly avatar Cain
Markos actions were given a whole new
meaning they were chaotic to be sure but
they were exactly as chaotic as said
Iraq wanted them to be black Tom's BFF
in uncanny x-men number 101 Chris
Claremont and Dave Cockrum introduced
one of the weirdest partnerships and
comics when the
not teamed up with black Tom Cassidy the
cousin of the x-man known as banshee in
the first story their Alliance really
only existed to justify the juggernauts
surprising presence and Cassidy keep but
the pair remained allies for years and
it's safe to say that black Tom got the
better end of that deal the juggernaut
is after all a legendarily unstoppable
supervillain who can level mountains and
bring down buildings with the single
punch black Tom Cassidy on the other
hand is more of a schemer and at one
point suffered from a disease that was
turning him into a tree not exactly the
most threatening mutants but when your
real power is being best friends with
the juggernaut
you don't really need to be juggernaut
versus everybody while he tends to
square off against the x-men the
juggernauts path of destruction isn't
just limited to the mutant corner of the
Marvel Universe
after all a huge guy who smashes through
walls and can't be stopped by any known
force is a useful sort of all-purpose
villain to have around he met dr.
strange for the first of several battles
in 1969 since getting his powers from a
demonic artifact made of a natural
villain for the sorcerer supreme
while the x-men were taking a break in
the early 1970s the juggernaut fought
the newly blue Beast in amazing
adventures number 16 and took on
Marvel's other famous unstoppable
behemoths in the Incredible Hulk number
172 he would throw down with Thor
several times including a story that
also introduced a team of young heroes
known as the new warriors and even
fought his share of bad guys during a
brief stint as a member of the x-men
of course he slugged it out with
Deadpool on plenty of occasions the
juggernauts greatest battle however
might also have been the single best
story he ever appeared in nothing can
stop the juggernaut in that story
juggernaut arrives in New York City in
an attempt to kidnap the psychic Madame
web spider-man tries to stop him but
finds out that the title of the story is
pretty accurate fortunately stopping the
unstoppable is what spider-man does for
all of his spidery abilities one of
Peter Parker's most important traits is
his unwillingness to give up no matter
how hopeless things might seem rather
than trying to match the juggernaut
physically spider-man eventually
outsmarts his unstoppable foe by
tricking him into burying himself and 40
feet of wet cement
the greatest bar fight ever the
juggernaut has met the x-men on plenty
of different battlefields but the most
memorable might be a dive bar in
Manhattan
it happened in uncanny x-men number 183
and was set in the aftermath of the
original secret wars among other things
that crossover saw Colossus falling in
love with an alien who promptly died
leading him to break up with his
longtime love interest Kitty Pryde once
he returned to earth
unfortunately for Colossus Wolverine has
always been protective of Kitty and
decides to take his Russian teammate out
to a bar get him drunk and then beat him
up he spared the trouble however by the
coincidental appearance of an out of
costume Cain Marko Wolverine manipulates
the two into fighting and then he and
nightcrawlers stand back and watch as
the two super-strong giants have one of
the greatest barroom brawls of all time
the entire establishment is destroyed in
the fight although the juggernaut
surprises everyone by donating a massive
roll of cash to fund its reconstruction
he takes off colossus learns his lesson
and wolverine is satisfied with the
night out x-men The Last Stand the
juggernaut made the cinematic debut in
2006's x-men The Last Stand with a very
charitable 58% rating on Rotten Tomatoes
that movie is commonly regarded as a bit
of a mess partly because it introduces a
ton of characters from the comics
without taking the time to actually make
them characters the juggernaut played by
Vinnie Jones definitely suffers from
this problem although there's one pretty
memorable scene don't you know who I am
I'm the geminal [ __ ]
when juggernaut is chasing Kitty Pryde
through a large building Kitty uses her
mutant powers to pass through the walls
but the juggernaut simply smashes
through them like the battering ram that
he is and as cool as that action is the
juggernaut dropping a reference to a
viral video featuring a fan dubbed
episode of the x-men cartoon is even
cooler Deadpool to the juggernauts
surprise appearance in Deadpool 2 wasn't
advertised but at this point the word is
out unlike the last stand
Deadpool twos juggernaut is an entirely
digital creation and gets to have a
massively over-the-top fight with his
old Comics rival Colossus in the credits
juggernaut is listed as playing himself
but screenwriter Rhett Reese revealed
the comic book resources that
juggernauts voice and facial capture are
actually performed by the same actor as
Deadpool Ryan Reynolds Colossus
negasonic teenage warhead and Yukio
managed to knock the juggernaut out at
the end of the film but is returned for
future sequels seems inevitable after
all nothing could stop the juggernaut
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]